this is so funny to me the bonsai body
yeah it really is the most spyware
looking [ __ ] of all time
i installed this little cute character
that does nothing and just says [ __ ]
every once in a while but just lives on
your computer
and is running constantly he was always
there
but he didn't do anything imagining
this network of 10 year olds just
staring at their computer
looking at this purple monkey and that
[ __ ] is just
in the background just hella binary just
like
just scraping the [ __ ]
just even like mouse mouse coordinates
on the screen
just everything just straight to a
server
and it's it's like it's like intense as
[ __ ] on the back end and you just cut to
the kid just looking at the camera just
looking
and then and then wait and then he just
here
i'm trying to pull up his voice
there he is
isn't it pasture bedtime sands undertale
what did he say isn't it past your
bedtime
he sounds like a grandpa let's get one
more line
bro to register the software it asks for
your [ __ ] name and address
oh my god this is hilarious you know we
did that you know we filled this out
honestly
because there is no reason why not oh
cool needs my address
word all right word sans undertale
let's take a moment and update our
automated registration card dude what
the [ __ ]
bro this is actually creepy as hell i
never went through very creepy
hold on let this run through what the
[ __ ]
when you finished simply click the
continue button below
i will automatically re-register you
what
what what happens wait i want to see
what happens after hits continue
of course this dude chooses he's 69
years old nice
smash it brother come on man do it dude
do
it bruh areas of interest
this is hilarious this is just one of
those like facebook surveys
yeah um
what the [ __ ] okay all right anyway damn
bonzo it's a pretty big discovery
yeah bonzie buddy was not your innocent
little primate friend
that you had on your screen it was much
more than that he was spying on you the
whole time
yeah he he was the sign of evil bro
i remember watching these documentaries
back in the day on like the history
channel or tlc or some [ __ ] and be like
there is a computer worm that is
purported to be
in all computers all over america and
they'd come up with these like covert
names and [ __ ] and it's like no it's
just
it's just ponzi buddy man
the whole time the whole it was right it
was right in front of our faces the
whole [ __ ] time
i can't believe he lied to us man i know
i trusted
i trusted him his voice was it was
weirdly soothing that like
like text-to-speech grandpa [ __ ] i used
to think it was dope now
now it's kind of creepy put your name
into the form and upload a picture of
yourself
have you ever wanted to go to a private
island
oh jesus oh
sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
you